[Music]
has this changed your attitude towards
what you do at all
um
it's changed my attitude is that i'm
going to be much more careful in the
future as far as you know i started i
basically kind of lost a little bit of
respect for the mountain i became too
comfortable too confident and i was
pushing way too hard i mean it's kind of
you know six feet is already close but
to try to push we were coming within
inches of things
i was just
i was stepping over what i should have
been doing and it basically spanked me
and i'm very happy that i i was able to
make a mistake so massive
and be able to recover from it because
usually when you make a mistake like
that i mean if you had told me before
that happened that i that you could
survive i would say it's impossible
you'll die for sure and in my mind when
i impacted
my brain was a hundred percent sure i
was dead and it was funny because i well
funny not funny at all but as i hit i
came off and my brain instantly split
into two
distinctive thought processes i thought
you meant it literally split in two no
which it may have it could have in my
head make contact yeah but basically my
thought process is one was a very
technical thought process of just what i
needed to do to survive i need to get
over that ledge i need to get over that
ledge i need to get over that ledge and
then the other part of my brain was
basically saying well
you're dead
why would you even pull it all
you basically got two options you can
you know just not pull and have a very
quick painless death or
pull and have a very painful
suffering you know awful death right and
it was a really kind of a struggle for
me because i was thinking man do i want
to suffer or do i just want it to just
be done and that's fascinating that all
of that goes through your mind in a
second yeah your brain everything slows
down your brain starts processing so
fast and all of a sudden the other part
of my brain is like you pull now or you
die right and i my the other part of my
brain that's kind of doing the argument
was like
good thing you like pain go for it you
know let's see if we can survive and
what it taught me is it taught me that
you know what no matter how bad you
think it is
never give up because guess what it may
not be as bad as you thought it would
that's a great i mean no that's uh yeah
well i'm glad you made the choice you
made i'm going and i have to ask
uh we're completely out of time but are
you gonna do this how soon you're gonna
do this again um well i'm supposed to be
walking without crutches in about two
weeks and then i should be able to start
jumping in about three months i'd do it
with the crutches all right
but that's just me i kind of live on the
edge